l'armée ukrainienne a repris la ville de
Kerson jusque là
occupé par les hommes de Vladimir
Poutine on va faire le point justement
sur la situation sur place en images et
puis on en parlera avec notre grand
reporter
le drapeau ukrainien flotte de nouveau à
Carson dans les rues l'armée prend ses
positions et appelle les derniers
soldats russes à se rendre les autorités
ukrainiennes savourent leur victoire
mais reste prudente
la désoccupation de la rive droite de la
région de Kerson et de la ville de
Kerson et dans sa phase finale
il y a beaucoup de travail à faire pour
nettoyer la zone et déminer la ville
nous comprenons que les occupants ont
détruit la centrale thermique et la
station de distribution d'électricité de
la région était
occupée depuis la mi-mars et avait été
annexée par Vladimir Poutine le 29
septembre dernier selon le Kremlin les
soldats sont tous quittés la zone depuis
ce vendredi
le transfert des troupes russes de la
rive gauche du fleuve Nièvre c'est
terminé à 5h heure de Moscou
pas une seule pièce d'artillerie n'a été
laissé sur place
tous les soldats russes ont traversé le
fleuve
il s'agit du troisième repli russe
d'ampleur depuis le début de l'invasion
le 24 février au printemps Moscou avait
renoncé apprendre Kiev avant
d'abandonner la quasi-totalité de la
région de kerkival est début septembre
la contre-offensive ukrainienne continue
de porter ses fruits et les troupes
russes sont désormais positionnés sur
l'autre rive du Flavien
naturelle malgré cette importance revers
Moscou précise que la zone reste un
sujet de la Fédération de Russie
arabophones de France 24 bonjour à vous
et personne reprise par l'armée
ukrainienne vous qui étiez sur place il
y a quelques jours encore est-ce que
c'est une surprise grande surprise parce
que cette rumeur qui disait que les
Russes vont se retirer et les sorties
oui jour avant cette annonce
d'aujourd'hui il arrivait de l'armée
ukrainienne dans cette blast qui est
très important et stratégique pour les
deux côtés donc la première fois les
militaires
Ukrainiens ils ont dit attention c'est
une pièce de l'armée russe donc nous
tant que les drapeaux
Ukrainiens ne flottent pas sur les
bâtiments de la ville on n'est pas et
ils sont toujours là bas et nous on se
prépare pour attaquer cette ville et la
reprendre coûte que coûte donc une
annonce surprise surtout aussi sur le
terrain les Russes se préparer à une
guerre longue ces derniers jours ils ont
vidé quand même 15 km de rive nord de la
ville ils ont déporté les populations
vers une autre
ville pour les Ukrainiens c'était une
crime contre l'humanité c'est ils ont
fait toutes une communication sur ça
parce que les Russes aussi se préparer
pour un combat de longue durée donc
cette décision était une décision de
surprise pour les deux côtés j'imagine
sauf que les militaires russes ils ont
toujours leur logique à eux il faut
savoir que cette cette décision c'est
pas la première c'est la troisième fois
que les militaires russes décident de se
replier on se rappelle de Kiev on se
rappelle de grandes parties de
raquifs et aujourd'hui Herson alors pour
eux c'est un repli militaire pour
préserver les forces russes qui se
misent quand même des pertes même nous
n'avoués certains dans certains mesures
mais quand même ils subissent et ils
veulent préserver la vie des soldats
selon le ministère russe sauf que pour
les Ukrainiens c'est des victoires c'est
des victoires parce que vu la différence
des forces les moyens des deux côtés les
moyens déployer militaires des deux
côtés les Ukrainiens ils sont en train
de gagner leur guerre et aujourd'hui nos
ministère de la Défense
ukrainienne communique dans ce sens et
le ministère dans son message qui
annonce l'arrivée des troupes
Ukrainiens dans la ville de Herson
s'adresse aux soldats russes restés
habillés en civile et caché selon les
conseils et les recommandations de leur
chef et de leur disent que vous qui vous
êtes resté en civil en espérant de
sortir comme ça on vous dit vous allez
pas sortir vous avez deux choix soit
baisser vos armes et vous rendre soit
vous allez mourir donc c'est une
stratégie c'est un discours une victoire
c'est pour ça que c'est surprenant alors
que les deux côtés se préparer à une
guerre longue pour Helson
[Musique]
pour varier et ne pas découvrir ce
position pour l'armée russe qui pullonne
avec des drones et aussi avec des de
l'aviation qui est super développé par
rapport aux Ukrainiens donc il y avait
des frappes continuelles de deux côtés
les Ukrainiens ils ont essayé aussi de
ce qu'ils appellent dans le jargon
militaire c'est déranger l'ennemi pour
ne pas le laisser se positionner et pour
le laisser toujours en état de tension
et les affaiblir psychologiquement donc
il préparait chaque jour des frappes et
qu'on a vu avec Jonathan wash et on a
fait des reportages avec des artilleurs
on a fait avec des tankistes qui
exercent des guérillas dans cette zone
de guerre c'est-à-dire ils font des
frappes ils reviennent alors passe
chaque jour donc cette guerre pour ces
soldats là c'est une guerre de langue
Allen et c'est préparé psychologiquement
pour une guerre qui dure donc c'est une
surprise c'est une victoire
pour les Ukrainiens parce que il y a pas
de perte pour l'armée
ukrainienne les Russes aussi ils ont
déclaré que le repli et c'était une
réussite ils ont perdu
ils ont rien laissé derrière eux ils ont
pas perdu de soldats dans ce repli cette
stratégie merci beaucoup à
pour ces